what do studio executives and producers
say about story structure or do they not
is it just this isn't working here or do
they narrow it I think it depends I mean
it's every studio so different now and
the studios have honestly they've
changed so much since when I started off
like I said a lot of them you know are
run by business people with no creative
background at all so you know they're
you know it sound like they're relying
on their creative team and that's not
that's not every studio buddy by any
means but but it has gotten a lot more
business oriented so I've been in a lot
of meetings where it's like it's this
isn't working for me I don't know why
but it's just not and they so they don't
know they just know that they don't like
it and so then you have to like try to
fish around to kind of figure out what
they don't like about it or what's not
working for them and and a lot of times
it's it's it's just a very interesting
business because you meet somebody
interesting type so you meet some really
great smart creative people you also
meet some people who got their jobs and
then you're like how does this person
like working you know I don't understand
because they obviously know nothing
about film and I'm gonna even saying
that like some of it's like sometimes
ridiculous where they'll say well can
you put like can you make all the people
13 it's like well they're caring machine
guns Eddie's in fighting monsters so
that might look a little ridiculous with
the 13 year old is a machine gun like
well just try it you know so a lot of
times you'll get nose like that or
they'll give you a really crazy note
that will derail you're like I don't
think a lot of people understand like
you know what you do knit a screenplay
together so if ya if you pull string out
over here it does have an effect in
other places a lot of times they'll be
like well just you know my the producers
sister wants a part so just give that
girl a best friend and just put her in
one scene like well then it wouldn't be
her best friend if she's only one scene
but then that affects all this other
stuff and they don't we'll just make it
work so you'll get that a lot of times
or it's like they'll give you like a
really crazy note so what I've learned
to do over the many many years now is is
you had to be a little passive
aggressive with them and you have you
because they do at the end of the day
everybody working the business at least
wants to be heard and you try to again
decipher what their note means if
they're know it sounds stupid like if
they're if they're saying you know well
if they're just telling you to put some
B's friend in the movie that's that's
not a creative note but if they're like
well we see there does need to be a cat
we just wanted I want a cat here and
you're you try to think well why do they
feel some
and have a cat here and then it's like
oh okay maybe there's like some emotion
that's missing here or there's like you
know because when you see a cat it just
gives you the warm fuzzies that maybe
there's something that's missing in this
scene that they want sometimes if you go
back to them and you say well I you said
you wanted a cat here but what I think
you were going for was that you're not
feeling this and this and like yeah
that's what I mean so a lot of it is
kind of deciphering what what they say
but as far as structure itself goes I
mean they'll build no structure a lot of
times but other times it's like it's
committee stuff so you know they'll have
a reader cover script first you know so
if the reader doesn't like it then all
times it won't even go to a development
executive or creative executive
critically the executive like said oh
goodness somebody higher up of somebody
up higher up it's like it likes it
they'll put it on their weekend read
which means that all the executive team
will read it and that's still a roll the
dice if they're gonna let you know so
it's it's a it's a tough business but
the great thing is there's so many other
companies out there besides the major
studios that you can go that's why I
always tell people to focus on because
um getting into the studio just really
hard because it really it's a machine
now like and so they're all putting out
remakes and sequels and things based on
comic books and video games and so all
their original content goes to their you
know if Chris Nolan wants to make
inception yes they will give him money
but then they're like well that's full
you know you know we've got all of the
Marvel movies coming out for five years
now and one one movie that's not a
Marvel movie so yeah they don't care so
much about structure so it's more of a
business model I think Oh a lot with the
studio's so you learn that any that it
helps you take your ego out a lot of
stuff so you don't take it personally
because it really it really is a
business I think they do care more about
business models and they do the script
structure do you know when that changed
I mean I realized you probably can't say
yes it was 2001 oh yeah no I mean I
think it I think it started to change in
the 90s you know I think it started
changing and then like because when I
start working at new line it was in the
early 90s and it was those I think it
you know 60s was very thats a lot of
tension you know 67 eight I think a lot
of that was creative but I think in the
90s as I think when a lot of the
corporations started wanting to
movie business so then you have like you
know Ted Turner buying like you know the
studio and then you know Warner Brothers
buying the studio and then then
everything too started turning into big
corporations and you know then when
you're it doesn't it you know this is no
offense to business people when you're a
business minded that's all you think
about is your bottom line that's like
well how can i Matt you know how can I
take off as many boxes to make sure this
movie has the widest appeal as opposed
to like if I make this really good movie
even though I don't get it at all you
know I'm gonna take a chance on it cuz I
trust that there will be enough people
that will watch it like that's why I
Love New Line Cinema you know cuz Bob
Shaye really fostered that it was a very
maverick you know thinking back then and
Mike De Luca was one of the really one
of the best development executives I
think that ever worked in a studio I
mean he was you know he would do a movie
and you know like a movie like blade he
would hit be like he wants to see a
black Vampire Slayer well a lot of
people you know who wants to see a movie
about a guy that puts on a mask and he's
you know can do this great who wants to
see him you know like about these two
really dumb guy you know he would come
he would really champ in all these
movies that most studios would never
ever take a chance on but he got the he
got it he's like no trust me you have to
trust me on this like people will go see
these movies and you don't see that that
I'm fearless as much anymore in studios
and that's just they just like to play
it safe unless you again you can just
see it from their slates that's why
they're you know they're remaking
remakes now and you know the thinking is
well if it's if people know the title
then that gives us a leg up over an
original film so it's a safer business
proposition so it's kind of that's why I
love people we might going to TV now is
because that's where you can go and be
creative and you know they're spinning
almost as much on TV stuff as they're
spinning on movies now and you can have
a really great creative storytelling and
not be like stifled so back when you
were at new line do you remember the
that people would know sort of character
arc and and it was much more about the
craft of writing that they could
understand and dissect certain parts and
why they didn't like it do you remember
um yeah no I think I think you know like
yeah I think in the develop meetings
there was definitely like there was
stuff that people the notes were
definitely much more like this isn't
working because of yeah it's not the
creative stuff isn't being satisfied in
it where
later on I was just like I don't like it
or there's not a big actor attached or I
can't make a toy out of it but you know
even new line they started a vision
called fine line that was more for their
art house films that didn't you know fit
the traditional blockbusters you know
structure or you know would probably win
an Academy Award but would probably not
make a lot of money so they created a
division especially to let like auteur
filmmakers do their thing you know
without having to worry about is this
going to make a hundred million dollars
at the box office or not
so yeah they were that was part of the
just film lover kind of company like
creating like an offshoot to make like
kind of artsy films that most people
would read the scripts would be like
well this is Helen Hunt with a piano and
her daughter I'm sitting on a Milano
where what does it make any sense so do
you remember the first movie you saw in
the theater um I don't actually which is
really really weird I remember seeing a
Miren Elm Street when a in 84 in
Kentucky in Kentucky I remember seeing
that when you were there sorry to
interrupt but ya think okay I were you
already thinking of writing this other
script no I just thought this is the
best movie I've ever seen in my life
because it was a double feature it was
like alone in the dark which new line
put out as well which was a slasher
movie about some escaped mental comment
you know minimal patients who get out
during a storm one night Jack Palance
was in it and terrorized like a town in
this house and and so nightmarish it was
a second movie after that so the first
one was scary but it was I mean I'm
straight when it comes to when you're 14
is like it was just brilliant like I was
like what the hell is this movie I'm so
just kind of blew my mind so it's it is
funny emili´s I mean I remember seeing
like Salem's Lot on TV but it is funny
as far as the movie theaters go for some
reason my brain is just oh no I do
remember I know this isn't the first one
I saw this is awful but they used to do
these like these are these movies and
they were they were rated R movies but
they were stupid like pom-pom girls or
something some cheerleader pop so my
cousins and my mom of all people is my
mom was a little bit of a hippie they
would take us to the drive-in and they
would sneak us in but they would make us
turn our backs to the screen during any
new DVD stuff but
but we'd sit with like a little pig I
remember I remember I don't remember the
name of the move it was something in the
pom-pom girls are some cheerleaders that
I think that was the first drive-in
movie I remember seeing but I remember
these
me and my sisters from over time with
our back to the to the screen meeting
eating popcorn and hot dogs and stuff
but um yeah I remember that because we
had a they had to sneak us in the
theater under him nice thinking good old
hippie
[Laughter]
you